[Music]
new covert variants aren't only making
the virus more transmissible
there are pending efforts to control
infection rates
this month south africa cancelled plans
to give people the astrazeneca jab
after finding it wasn't effective enough
against the local variant
uh it was definitely disappointing uh
here in the
much slower than expected efficacy of
the astrazeneca vaccine
time is ticking no one knows when and
how new variants will affect
transmission
and whether the current vaccines will
work
the uk is stepping up testing to stop
virus variants from spreading
up to 10 percent of positive tests are
sent to labs for further genome analysis
in the global fight against covid19 is
mutations that are proving
the next great challenge and here in the
uk authorities are taking that fight
directly into people's homes guys
they're doing door-to-door covert
testing in areas where new mutations
have been found
the goal to identify cases before they
have a chance to spread
it it was just one case of the south
african variant found here
in this community that launched this
door-to-door testing scheme
but the concern is that one case could
just be the tip of the iceberg
ordinarily only a small amount of
positive covert tests are screened for
mutations
meaning that when they are found
authorities here are cracking down hard
it's thanks to genome sequencing that
authorities can pinpoint where to look
the uk is the world leader in sequencing
analyzing 10
of positive covert samples for the
emergence of new variants
in total the team at the uk's covert 19
genomics consortium
is responsible for almost half the
world's coronavirus sequencing
work that will continue to prove crucial
as more mutations emerge
i don't think we've seen the full
spectrum of mutations that could arise
so the variant that's common in england
at the moment they're 117.
that's very good at spreading but
actually what i'm looking for very
carefully
is mutations going into that variant
that also impact on immunity and that's
what starts to worry me considerably
and that is what we're seeing in the uk
but no population is immune to mutations
that's why professor peacock says genome
sequencing needs to become a global
priority
without comprehensive international
screening it's feared new more dangerous
variants could take hold
putting vaccine programs at risk
mutations will be
in the four corners of the earth and
there'll be lots that we
don't know about that we'd be quite
concerned if we did know about now the
reason that's important for all of us is
because some of these variants
are actually going to lead to a
challenge in terms of immunization
now that is is really critical as we go
forward we need to know what the virus
is doing
so that we can keep up with vaccine
development
work is already being done to modify
vaccines to protect against existing
variants
[Music]
professor paul heath is the chief
investigator of the uk's novovax vaccine
trial
he says he's confident sequencing can
help manufacturers
keep ahead of mutations one of the
beauties of the
vaccine technologies or platforms that
we're seeing
now uh in the production of covet 19
vaccines is that they are very
efficient and flexible and
and so it's entirely possible now
that um modified vaccines will emerge
very quickly
from the these different vaccine
manufacturers
vaccines will likely have to adapt in
the meantime
identifying and isolating mutations will
be an invaluable tool
in the cat and mouse game between
vaccines and variants
julian tonga is a consultant virologist
at the leicester royal infirmary
the new mutations are called variants of
concern
how concerned are you
so i'm not that concerned i think our
national immunity will adapt to these
variants i think most people are
concerned because they may be more
transmissible
so they may overwhelm healthcare service
for those who need hospitalization
and there's also some vaccine escape
properties that some of them are showing
that may reduce the efficacy of the
current vaccine
but then we just have to update them as
we do every year for flu
okay so no panic yet but what about the
various variants tell us about the
bristol liverpool variant
the the south african one
yeah so the original kent variant b117
did not have the 484k mutation that
seems to be
conferring vaccine escape properties but
now the b117 ken berry has acquired the
484k
and it's now called the bristol variant
but also uh
the previously existing circulating
strain from the original wuhan
chinese variant has now acquired the 44k
is
alright so case is now kind of
infiltrating the uk
circulating sales kb2 viruses and then
of course these 44k is already present
in the south african variant and the
brazilian variants
and it seems to be a kind of global
adaptation to the human host
okay you're just breaking up a little
there but uh i'm getting the gist of it
what what does the data actually
show us about these uh variants
so the original b117 variant seems to be
more transmissible
uh there were some confounders in that
but it seems to be spreading more
quickly throughout the uk population and
also in other places like australia for
example
and perhaps journey where you've got
some cases the um
bristol and liverpool variants have come
on top of that
may well show some vaccine escape
properties um
additional research on the original b117
kent variant suggests
some perhaps some increased severity
but that hasn't been separated from the
normal winter seasonal effects
of enhanced mortality mobility due to
pre-existing conditions like
hypertension diabetes heart disease etc
so there is still some um doubt about
the
um true effect of that on clinical
severity
also the original b117 variant the kent
variant
may have a wider spectrum of clinical
symptoms compared to the previous
circulating strain and it may well be
that
it presents more more with respiratory
symptoms and less with things like loss
of
taste and smell but again this is
ongoing the numbers still need to be
improved and increased before we can be
definitive about this
and what about the effects of weather at
the moment they're called weather and
hospitalizations as well
yeah so that's what i just mentioned the
seasonal winter cold may
exacerbate a lot of the comorbidities
that these patients present with
and giving the impression that you know
this variant is more severe
at this time so again this is the kent
variant the b117 variant
uh we don't have enough data for the
liverpool and bristol variants to make
any comment like this
but the data so from the b117 kenpo
suggests
more transmissibility and more severity
of the illness
at least bringing hospital people to
hospital but once they're in hospital
there's no increase in mortality
and that that relative increase in
so-called severity is about
30 to 70 percent compared to what it was
on the previous
original wuhan chinese strain of the
variant again that's subject
to indoor crowding during winter and
enhanced mortality mobility
due to these pre-existing conditions
during the colder winter months
so i think it's not entirely certain yet
that this very
really causing all those extra effects
separate from
the winter indoor crowding and the
winter increased mobility mortality
of those pre-existing conditions and
just really really briefly in which
direction do you think sasko v2 is
actually evolving now
oh i think we're seeing the viruses
evolving to
a more transmissible host adaptive
strain with the e484k
and the additional mutations we're
seeing with the b17 variants as well as
the south african and brazilian variants
and the fact that these 44k 501 and 417
mutations occurring
independently across the world in
different variants from different
countries suggest that this
these are the true active mutations that
we're seeing now
to the human population julian tong
thank you very much
your questions now here's our science
correspondent derek williams
i've heard that like influenza sarskoff
ii is destined to become endemic even
with widespread global vaccination
is that true this is another million
dollar question that no one yet
knows the answer to but increasingly it
appears to be yes
to understand why let's look at all the
things that would have to happen
to make the answer no instead in other
words
what would it take to put the genie back
in the bottle
and eradicate covet 19 completely
well as one who official put it that's a
a very high bar several factors would
play key roles in whether or not we
could even
hope to do it one is the extent to which
people are protected by a natural
infection
and b vaccination we now know
that getting sick with covet 19 provides
a protective shield
for at least half a year or so but not a
perfect one
people can get reinfected after time
has passed which is is not a surprise as
that happens with
other coronaviruses too assuming
reinfected people also infect others
which is
a pretty good bat you end up in the long
run
with a circular fairly stable system
of a certain number of people regularly
passing it along
to a certain number of others whose
immunity
has lapsed it's endemic if vaccines can
spur
long-lasting immune responses and and
help
prevent transmission two things that we
still don't really know yet
um then it would give us a fighting
chance
of breaking the circle but but that
would take
moving fast with vaccination programs on
a really massive scale worldwide because
we're also in a race against a mutating
viral enemy
with with new variants arising all the
time
and as long as large numbers of people
remain unvaccinated wherever they are
they'll continue to provide a reservoir
for the virus and
and also a space for it to evolve
potentially turning progress we've made
so far into a a
two steps forward one step back
situation
um before i ruin your day though please
remember
another important thing um we can still
end
this pandemic even if sars coke 2
does become endemic all that means
is that that once we have the situation
in hand to some extent
in the future we'll have to react
quickly to
outbreaks with effective control
measures
and and we've been developing an arsenal
of those
for a year now
derek could never ruin my day thanks for
watching stay safe and i'll see you
again very soon here on dw
bye